LISA GREEN: OK.
Thank you guys.
Thanks everyone for coming.
First, I'm Lisa Green.
I run our Luxury Fashion Group.
And I'm thrilled to have
these four guys here
to talk to us today about
how shopping has changed
in the modern day, and give
any advice that any of you guys
have about that specific topic.
So we'll go ahead and
start with Lauren.
And then we'll just
go down the line.
LAUREN SHERMAN: My
name's Lauren Sherman.
I am Fashionista's
editor-at-large.
I'm a freelance writer as well.
And I write for a bunch
of different publications.
My expertise is kind
of the intersection
of fashion and business.
So I write for
consumer publications.
I write for business
publications, trade
and-- So I've been covering
this stuff for about 10 years.
And e-commerce is obviously
a big part of my beat.
So I guess that's basically it.
LEAH CHERNIKOFF: Hi.
I'm Leah Chernikoff.
I'm the editor of Elle.com.
So that means I oversee all
editorial, content, strategy.
Before that I was at
Fashionista with Lauren.
She hired me.
And before that, I was a
reporter at the Daily News,
covering features.
And then I focused on
fashion from there.
And also decided to
go digital, when,
I think I experienced the
fourth round of layoffs.
So I'm happy to be online.
And so-- yeah, my
expertise is more
of sort of a general
view on fashion,
and having watched,
sort of, things
go from analog to digital.
LISA GREEN: You've got it.
STEVEN ALAN: Hi I'm Steven Alan.
And I started my company
about 20 years ago.
And started as a multi-brand
retailer and then from there
started representing
designers, and then from there,
started manufacturing.
And today, we do all three,
kind of three businesses
within a business.
And I think each business
is very much complementary
to the other business.
BRETT HEYMAN: Thank you.
Hi, my name is Brett Heyman.
I have a brand of
handbags called Edie.
Parker, which I launched
about four years ago.
And before that, I
had a PR background.
I worked in PR for Gucci
and Dolce Gabbana covering
accessories, mostly,
and ready-to-wear.
LISA GREEN: Cool.
Well thank you guys.
Thank you again for being here.
We're just going to
kick it off by asking
what the strangest thing that
you've ever bought online is?
So, Steven, we'll
start with you.
STEVEN ALAN: I remember
buying a car online,
which for me was pretty weird.
Without seeing it,
and it was on eBay,
and it was one of
those bidding things--
And it was a
particular-- it wasn't
any amazing-- it was
just an old Volvo.
But I wanted a stick-shift.
And so I ended up going up to
Pittsburgh and picking it up .
It wasn't that weird but--
LISA GREEN: It's a big purchase.
STEVEN ALAN: Yeah, it
was a big purchase.
LISA GREEN: Brett.
You want to go?
BRETT HEYMAN: Well, I'm excited
to hear that because I'm
mulling over a Grand Wagoneer
online, and through eBay Auto.
So I'm happy that
it worked for you.
I don't think I buy
a lot of weird stuff.
But I do buy a lot
of geodes and rocks,
and I buy them all
online on eBay.
LISA GREEN: Well, I'm just
going throw in what my weirdest
thing was-- to
maybe help you guys
along the continuum of weird--
I once bought a smitten, which
was actually a glove
for two people.
So that you could hold hands--
[LAUGHTER]
--while walking down the street.
It's really-- I've been
married for 10 years.
So clearly that was
more than 10 years ago.
[LAUGHTER]
LEAH CHERNIKOFF: We were
talking about this before.
I'm like kind of co-opting
my boyfriend because he
buys a lot of
weird drugs online.
[LAUGHTER]
And, they come in like strange--
LISA GREEN: Remember,
we are video'ing this.
LEAH CHERNIKOFF:
Yeah, that's fine.
They're all legal.
[LAUGHTER]
LAUREN SHERMAN:
Now, I really want
to know what kind
of legal drugs?
Is it like through
Canada or something?
[LAUGHTER]
LEAH CHERNIKOFF:
[INAUDIBLE] from Asia.
LAUREN SHERMAN: Oh, interesting.
OK.
We can talk about this offline.
I think the weirdest
thing I've ever bought
is like a dog DNA test.
I don't know if that's
that weird though.
I mean, you guys are
doing stuff like that now.
LISA GREEN: It's weird.
LAUREN SHERMAN: And I've
tried to buy my own DNA test.
But there are weird
rules in New York.
And I've also bought like,
the "National Geographic."
It's like the "23 and Me"
thing, but what they do.
And it's $100 bucks.
But the doggie DNA was
probably the weirdest.
And it confirmed
what we already knew.
So it was also a
waste of money, but--
[LAUGHTER]
--it was good.
STEVEN ALAN: What was that
"National Geographic"?
I'm just curious about that.
LEAH CHERNIKOFF: It's
all about her ancestors.
LAUREN SHERMAN: You
like-- it's another story.
It's too long.
But, you like--
they take your DNA.
And they find out
one-- I think it's
like your grandmother's
grandmother.
Or guys can do-- women can't
do the guy's lineage too--
but you can find out like
one path of your lineage.
And again, it was everything
that I already knew.
It was not-- there was nothing
exciting in there, except one.
But yeah.
So.
LISA GREEN: All right.
Well, thanks guys.
Now, the rest of this is gonna
be so boring in comparison.
But, let's just start
pretty general with what's
the biggest change that you see
in the way people are shopping?
Leah, you've got the
mike, so why don't you--
LEAH CHERNIKOFF: Um, I think
what I've noticed most,
and what I'm guilty of myself,
with everything being online
now, is if you see
one thing online,
I immediately go to
like 10 other sites
to see which site has it at
the cheapest price point.
So I think that's
really changing
the way-- people
aren't just maybe going
to one online
shopping destination.
But sort of scoping it out.
I don't know.
We were talking about
the death of Huckster,
but that's kind of
what that did, right?
LISA GREEN: If anybody
else has anything to add,
or we could move on to the next.
You've got something, Steven?
STEVEN ALAN: No.
Go ahead.
LISA GREEN: Nothing?
OK.
In terms of devices,
I think that's kind of
been the big theme
lately is, we're all
talking about being multi-screen
and going from one device
to the next, and kind
of switching it all up?
Which one do you think has
become the most influential
on purchase decisions?
So not necessarily which one
is the one with the last click,
because I think that we're
all aware of what that is.
But what do you think?
You know, from TV to a magazine,
to a phone, to a computer,
to a billboard, to
in-store signage-- what
do you think really has the
most influence on purchasing
decisions?
Steven.
STEVEN ALAN: I
think that, I mean,
mobile is definitely the
most important thing.
And I think that now
what we're seeing
is definitely sort of the tablet
gaining more and more strength
compared to the phone.
Just because people are just
able to carry it around in.
They're smaller.
And even the phones are
becoming more like tablets.
So the line is getting blurred.
LISA GREEN: The phablet?
STEVEN ALAN: Yeah.
I guess.
LISA GREEN: Anything
else you guys think?
Like, why do you think mobile
and tablet are becoming so big?
LAUREN SHERMAN: Yeah.
Obviously I agree
that mobile is huge.
I just did a story this weekend
on buying fine jewelry online,
for the "Wall Street
Journal"'s Weekend Section.
And a lot of these fine
jewelry retailers-- people
are buying $60,000 pairs
of earrings on their phone.
And I mean, that's been
happening in Asia for years.
But now it's becoming
more prevalent here.
But I also think that the phone
and the tablet connect you.
If you're in the store and
you see something-- and all
this cross-channel stuff
that people call Omni Channel
or whatever-- is those
things are the connectors.
So whether that means
going into a store
and them having tablets
for you to buy more stuff.
Or that means you looking
on your phone, that's
the thing that's
really connecting us,
is the mobile aspect of it.
And
LISA GREEN: And what do you guys
think is that big opportunity?
I think Lauren makes a
really good point about how
mobile kind of connects
you while you're in store.
If you could sort
of create-- Steven,
maybe for you in your stores?
How do you feel like your--
you guys should be using mobile
once somebody is already there?
STEVEN ALAN: We do.
I mean we have
iPads in the stores.
And people come in
the store and then,
if we don't have something,
then usually the associate
will go online and see
if we have it online.
Then they'll be able to
help them and complete
that purchase online.
Or, if another store
has it, again they
can check inventory with the
same app at and other stores,
and sell that.
Had
LAUREN SHERMAN: Yeah,
it's such a simple thing.
But my husband's a big
fan of Steven's stuff.
And he-- that, like,
sea-green sweatshirt you guys
did for spring?
He really wanted it.
But it was sold out
on his size online.
And it said on there that it was
available in the Tribeca store.
So he went there.
That's something that's
been around for a long time.
But I feel like people
are really using it now.
Whereas maybe five years ago,
he wouldn't have even thought
of checking to see if it
was available in a store,
or he would have picked
up the phone and called,
instead of figuring it online.
STEVEN ALAN: That's
also-- I mean,
for us, that was definitely like
101, was being able to do that.
And if we didn't have it online,
just have it pop up and say,
sorry we're out of that.
But we have it.
And it would be by the SKU.
So it won't tell you to call
a store if they don't actually
have that size in that item.
But then, 2.0 would
definitely be--
online would actually just
start scanning all the stores.
And then be able to just
continue that order without you
having to call the store
and have the store ship it
to you and all that stuff.
The store would still do that.
But you wouldn't
necessarily know that.
And so I think that
for me, as a retailer
I want to really make that
whole experience as seamless
as possible.
So sometimes you don't want
to even necessarily buy it.
You want to kind of see it,
or touch it, or feel it.
So, to be able to be at home
at 2 o'clock in the morning,
go online and just shop, but
actually not purchase and say,
you know what?
Tomorrow I'd like
to try that on.
I'll be in the
store at 2 o'clock.
And you know, have that
whole experience happen.
That's something that-- I don't
know who's doing that at all.
But that's something
that I want to do.
Because I think it's important.
You want to be able to do that.
LISA GREEN: I saw
a study recently
that said that
people would prefer
to consult their phone
than a sales associate.
So even when they
walk into a store,
the first thing that they do
is they look at their phone,
rather than ask for help.
And in fact people
will say, is there
something I can help you with?
Can I help you?
And they say, oh no no.
No thanks.
And there they are,
on their phone.
So what do you suggest?
How do you think you can
use that to your advantage?
Or how could a retailer use
that to their advantage,
rather than it being
something that's
coming between the customer?
STEVEN ALAN: I mean,
that's definitely something
that we're seeing.
People are coming
into the store,
and they're definitely trying
to get more information
on products while
they're in the store.
And I think in the
future, whether it's
QR codes or something, where you
can actually really do a deeper
dive-- Because I think that even
the people working in the store
have a limited amount
of information.
But what you can
actually-- you can videos.
You can do anything,
depending on the product.
LISA GREEN: Maybe
Brett, maybe we
can loop you into to the
conversation a little bit,
in terms of, what
brands do you think
are doing interesting
things with all
of these-- the direction
that shopping is moving in?
Have you seen
anything interesting?
BRETT HEYMAN: Well, I myself am
obsessed with personalisation.
Like, we launched
our website mid-June.
And we have a bespoke component
where you can type in your name
and see how it
would look on a bag.
And so I would love to
develop that further.
And so in that
vein, I'm obsessed
with the Nike interface,
when you can do the bespoke.
But I also love how
Warby Parker does
the-- you can upload your
face and try on the glasses
virtually.
It is my dream to have a virtual
dressing room for my body,
and just have your
body up there,
and have your virtual
clothes, and never ever ever
have to try on
anything in real time.
[LAUGHTER]
LISA GREEN: What about you guys?
Have you seen anything, any
brands that you would call out
as doing anything
really interesting?
LEAH CHERNIKOFF: I don't know.
Nothing comes to mind for me.
LAUREN SHERMAN: I think Nike and
personalization stuff is cool.
I mean, I think there
are the obvious ones.
Burberry and you know, that
get called out again and again
and again.
But I think, there's a brand
in the UK called "Matches."
They sell a lot.
They have a huge
presence online.
But they sell a lot of-- they
have a bunch of boutiques.
They sell really
expensive clothes.
And they have a thing.
They sell tons of SKUs online.
Tons of denim.
Tons of contemporary.
So most of you work, I
think, in ad, fashion ads,
so you probably
know contemporaries,
like mid-price stuff.
But they don't have much
of that in the boutique,
because they don't have
a lot of square footage.
They only have dressed
that are $1,000 or more.
So when they're in the
store, they have iPads out.
And they're kind of
training their probably very
well-paid customer service
people to kind of loop
in the stuff on the iPad.
And anecdotally, they've
told me that a lot of people
who have never
bought stuff online
before are buying jeans through
them, or a pair of earrings,
or something like that,
while they're in the store.
So I think that kind of
stuff, it's still clunky.
And it's not where
it needs to be.
But the more that happens,
the more exciting shopping
is going to become.
LISA GREEN: And a little bit
in the personalization vein,
we were discussing
a little bit earlier
that, I read an
article this morning
about how big data can really
play a role in personalization.
The article was about this
guy who had received an email
to install solar
panels on his home.
But it was really personalized.
The company had used the
Google Maps technology
and overlaid their own
API, whatever they did.
And they said they found
that this guy's house was
perfect for installing
solar panels.
And so the email said that.
It said, we've
done some research.
And your house is
great for solar panels.
And he clicked on it.
And the link brought him to
another personalized place
that had Google Earth imagery.
And said, here's what we would
do with your solar panels.
And the next clip
was to a rep, who
already had all his
information and was ready.
He didn't have to say anything.
It was such a powerful
way to use data,
instead of it just
being, oh, well
you bought a pair of jeans.
So you should buy more jeans.
Here's 30% off.
What do you guys think could
be done in the fashion space
with all this data that
we now have access to?
STEVEN ALAN: I think
that it's interesting.
Because I was just
in L.A. last weekend.
And I started getting
emails-- and I'm not even sure
how this was done, but--
I started getting emails
for companies that
had L.A. stores,
but where I never received
the emails from those stores.
I don't even know how they knew.
I was just thinking about that.
But I think that-- Definitely,
like for example right now,
another initiative
is, if you come
into the store as
a customer, you
have your history of what
you've bought from the store.
And then we have a history
of what you've bought online.
But the sales
associates can't really
access what you've
bought online, yet.
I mean, they will be able to.
But I think that is
really important,
to be able to see sort
of a complete profile.
And another thing that
we're going to be using
is a technology called
Digital Marvels or Touche.
I'm not sure which company.
But it's interesting.
What they do is,
they allow the person
who's at the store to be
able to sort of drag and drop
very easily.
So if you're a customer, and
you want to find out information
on a particular brand-- you're
interested in acne, say,
now what's happening
is you might
get an email with a couple links
on different items, whatever.
But with this, you'd could
actually get-- I mean,
it's an app.
You'd have to download the app.
But then it would just be
really easy for the associate
to just sort of drag
a bunch of things
that they think that you
might be interested in.
And then you could
drag a bunch of things
out that you're
not interested in.
It just really facilitates
a great experience.
LAUREN SHERMAN: Yeah.
I'm actually working on a
story about this right now.
And I think Gilt does a
really interesting job
with this stuff.
They have a ton
of people working
on their personalization.
They have a huge team of
engineers working on it.
And I think that they've
actually done the best job.
You know, they
think about climate.
They think about where you are.
They think of your size.
And they really try
to whittle it down.
So you get an email that
is only the products
that you'd actually want.
Does it always work?
No.
But they're doing
interesting things with.
And I think also it
can help in the buying
process for a lot
of big retailers.
The way that
retailers buy things
is kind of very-- they
look at past data.
And now they'll be able
to look current data,
and say, oh, people
across the internet
are buying green
shirts or whatever.
Maybe we should
order or we should
get some green shirts
made, things like that.
So I think there's a
lot of different ways
it can be applied.
Some of them, it might
not be worth all the time
and effort, the end result.
But I think,
especially if you're
a big, big multi-brand website,
to be able to kind of figure
out what's available in
people's sizes, in the things
that they'd already
like, is exciting.
And the better that they get
at it, the more-- I guess,
the less people
will even notice,
or, hopefully it will
result in better sales.
LEAH CHERNIKOFF: [INAUDIBLE].
LISA GREEN: OK.
So what about shifting
gears a little bit?
What about social?
What platforms do you think
are really making a difference?
I think that what
we see is brands
are really going after
kind of every platform.
They're on Pinterest.
They're on Instagram.
They're on YouTube.
They're on Facebook.
And in fact, their marketing has
every little icon next to it.
Which ones do you
guys really think
are actually having an
influence, driving purchase?
And as a brand,
which ones do you
feel like you are best
able to sort of communicate
your own messaging from?
And from where you guys sit,
which brands-- what's working
and why?
STEVEN ALAN: I mean
for us, I would
say Instagram is probably
the most effective.
Because it's just so visual.
I think that we can sort of
connect the dots with Instagram
better than anything else.
And then with Instagram, goes
to Twitter, goes to Facebook.
So it's very strong.
We're about to launch another
app called Spring, which
will be-- I think
it's going to be very
significant in
the fashion space.
Because it will actually be
a shoppable visual platform.
So I think I'm
excited about that.
BRETT HEYMAN: For us also,
Instagram's the most important.
Being a small brand, and
just communicating directly
with the customers,
anytime I post a picture
that people like that,
I have so many people
asking if we'll ship to Mexico?
If we'll ship here,
and how much bags are.
So I can directly interface
with the customers.
And I get so many screenshots
of an Instagram post
sent back to our
customer service
saying we want to
order this bag.
Where do we get this bag?
So it's great.
And then if there were ever--
if we want to do sales,
or now launching the website and
promoting sales on the website,
we use Facebook.
And I feel like that customer
is much more into what
your sales are,
what deal can I get.
It's much more commerce-driven
than the visual, Instagram.
LEAH CHERNIKOFF: Yeah.
I would say Instagram too.
And I also think
that Spring is going
to be a game changer, maybe.
I don't know if you
guys know what it is.
But as I understand it-- and I'm
getting a walk-through tomorrow
actually, of the app.
But I've seen it in
its early stages too.
It's like an Instagram feed,
but you can click to buy.
And it's really, really
beautifully designed,
and really intuitive.
So, I don't shop
online that much.
That one makes a
lot of sense to me.
So I think that--
and every major brand
is signing up with them.
So I think that will be a force.
But other than
that, yeah, I think
Instagram is such a
great way for brands
to present exactly the
image that they want.
But then also you
see Style Bloggers,
and I think, what is
it, Like To Know It?
LAUREN SHERMAN: Like To Know It.
LEAH CHERNIKOFF: I did
talk to a few bloggers.
They are seeing commissions.
So I think it's working too.
It's another way to make
Instagram shoppable.
That one seems like
more effort to me,
like, you have to sign up.
And then more steps.
But I think, when somebody
sees something on a girl
that they think looks really
cute, and they want the dress,
it's a good way to get it.
LAUREN SHERMAN: Yeah, I agree.
Instagram and Spring-- I'm
also really excited about.
I think, if anybody's
going to be able to do it--
what companies like
List and I'm trying
to think of what the other
ones are called, and Fancy,
have tried to do with fashion
and have not been able to.
I really think Spring might
have a chance to do it.
Especially because it's--
they're doing partnerships.
It's not affiliate-based
as I think I'm correct?
STEVEN ALAN: What do you mean?
Partnerships as opposed to?
LAUREN SHERMAN: As opposed
to just a feed, API.
STEVEN ALAN: Oh, no.
It's total partnerships.
LAUREN SHERMAN: Yeah.
So it's not an API.
So it's just very interesting.
And I think that when that
launches, if it takes off,
it's going to be huge.
Or it will flop it.
But I have a feeling it's
going to be really good.
LISA GREEN: So it'll
be good, or not good.
LAUREN SHERMAN: Yeah.
LEAH CHERNIKOFF: But you
create the imagery, right?
STEVEN ALAN: Yeah.
LEAH CHERNIKOFF: So
every brands creates--
like, they have
complete control.
So I think that that's
part of the reason it
will be so successful.
LISA GREEN: So, in
that vein, do you
think that there's a danger of
kind of commercializing what
consumers feel like is
somewhat organic at this point?
So, in the same way, like
maybe, if I think about it
from a video aspect,
should brands
be making their
videos more shoppable?
Should there be this sort
of seamless interaction
between a beautiful brand
video that you could actually
click to buy?
Or do you think--
because it sounds
like what you guys are saying
is, Instagram's awesome.
And it'll be more awesome
if you can buy from it.
So do you think it's
the same with video?
LAUREN SHERMAN: I don't think
many people watch fancy brand
videos.
LEAH CHERNIKOFF: [INAUDIBLE]
actually launched today.
Cinematique, did you see that?
LAUREN SHERMAN: Yeah.
They've been doing stuff
on [INAUDIBLE] for a while.
But it could work.
And it's interesting.
But I think what sells are
YouTube people, like vloggers.
I think that they can really
sell product via the web.
And I think on the
really high end, I mean,
I think occasionally
it does work.
And there are certain
viral fashion videos
that have done well.
And maybe if they had click
to buy on them-- like,
Rachel Antonoff does
some really cool ones.
If they had had click to buy,
maybe it would have done well.
But I think that
that's something
that bigger brands
haven't figured out yet.
STEVEN ALAN: I'd
heard the other day
that I think there was
15,000 people on YouTube that
have a greater
following than Vogue.
LAUREN SHERMAN: Oh yeah.
STEVEN ALAN: It
was just amazing.
LAUREN SHERMAN: Yeah, and even
if people are watching things
on Vogue-- I mean, Leah
could speak to this more
because I haven't been
editing a site for a while.
But it's really hard to get
people to shop via editorial,
when you're a really big name.
If you're a blogger,
it's easier.
Because they have a
closer connection.
But to get someone to buy
something via a story,
it's not really why people are
going to editorial websites.
I don't know that's changing.
Do you think it is?
LEAH CHERNIKOFF: No.
I think it's easier online.
Because throughout the day, we
have smaller market stories.
And they're much more focused.
Or maybe one is really centered
around an editor who functions
in that way more like a blogger.
Because then you sort of
might follow that editor
on their social
channels and feel
a more personal connection.
So if they pick the product,
maybe wear it themselves,
you might be more inclined
to buy it than maybe
if you just saw like a
roundup of like 100 boots.
But you might get a sense of
the direction you want to go in.
I still think it offers
guidance, but not
in the same way of an immediate
sort of drive to sale.
And then this thing that-- I got
a walk-through of Cinematique
which makes shoppable videos.
And it launched with
Net-a-Porter today.
And I still, I mean as
someone who runs a site,
it's hard to get
people to watch videos.
Like, we don't have a user's
attention for very long.
And so the videos
have to be short.
And I think, it's
also just going to--
you have to change the way users
interact with video, to let
them know like, oh, you
can hover over the video
and click things in.
And I think that's
just not-- it's really
going to have to
be a behavior shift
to let people know
that that's possible.
LISA GREEN: Cool.
I'm going to open
it up for questions.
I can keep asking them.
But I don't if anybody in
the audience has anything.
You can just raise your hand
if you've got any questions.
Oh, OK.
AUDIENCE: What do you
think is the next big thing
in e-commerce in
regards to shopping?
Or what would you
like to see next?
LAUREN SHERMAN: I
think that beauty
is something has a
lot of opportunity.
There's a ton of
opportunity via YouTube
and beauty, which is
already happening.
But I think that the beauty
space-- a lot of beauty brands
have a weird rule that if you
don't have any brick and mortar
store, you can't sell
their stuff online.
And someone explained to me
why that is the other day.
Because every beauty person I
meet, I ask them why that is.
But they're really
strict about it.
So a lot of beauty sites that
don't have brick and mortar,
they don't have a
lot of big brands.
And I think that that's
going to start-- I mean,
Amazon has everything.
Because they pool from--
it's not regulated.
And obviously you guys
know how that works.
But I think beauty
is a huge space.
It doesn't-- as much as people
say you need to try on product,
people have been shopping via
Avon catalogs for 100 years
or whatever.
I don't think that
that's a barrier.
And I think there aren't
that many big players.
There's Amazon.
There are the bigger websites.
And there is Sephora.
But there isn't a
ton in that space.
And that to me, that's
what I'm looking at,
at different e-commerce
opportunities in there.
And I also think just the
closer connection with in-store.
I mean, there was
some survey that
said that people still
prefer to shop in-store.
I haven't looked
at the data enough
to know whether or
not it was BS or not.
But I think that people
are using the web.
Regardless, every
purchase is made with web.
So just the closer the
connection is between the two,
the better off the
retailer is, I think.
LISA GREEN: You guys have
anything about e-commerce.
STEVEN ALAN: I would just--
I think when 3D-- I mean,
that's going to be revolutionary
in shopping, I think.
And just quality
imagery in general.
When we photograph things,
it's always just the lighting
and being able to
really see color.
So I think as
technology advances,
that's going to really
help with things like that.
LISA GREEN: One of
the other questions
that I have which, I
haven't gotten to ask yet,
which seems like a right to
ask it is, so if Google could
design the perfect product for
fashion brands, what would that
look like to you guys?
What's missing in this space
that you think you really
need to drive your sales,
or to promote your brand,
or that you really think
is missing to make fashion
more exciting, more
accessible, more Interesting?
Leah?
I'm gonna call on Leah.
LEAH CHERNIKOFF: That's
a really big question.
LISA GREEN: OK.
Brett?
BRETT HEYMAN: I'm sticking
with virtual dressing room.
LISA GREEN: That's right.
You nailed it.
BRETT HEYMAN: It's
applicable for beauty, too.
Uplighting your face,
what colors work?
I just feel like that's
going to be everything.
STEVEN ALAN: I think
checkout, too, is a big deal.
I mean obviously,
like Amazon checkout,
it just makes it so easy.
But I think just
having this sort
of seamless one-click
ability to do
that, I think it'll
help with that.
LEAH CHERNIKOFF: And making
returns as easy as possible,
too.
I mean, I think that's the
number one thing that stops me
from shopping online is because
I know that, if I get it,
and then I wait too
long, I'm screwed.
And I've got it.
So I tend to only make
purchases when I really
know that it's
something like-- brand
that I love, the
size of that fits me.
And I know all
these things work.
STEVEN ALAN: And you were
saying in the beginning,
you were saying about
checking different sites
to see who had it
at a lower price?
I would think that if there
was an app that actually could
do that for you, where
you just automatically
have whatever the sites
that you would check.
And it would just tell you, OK.
Buy it.
It's cheapest.
LEAH CHERNIKOFF: And you would
have a definitive answer.
STEVEN ALAN: So they do
it with air fare now.
So it seems like, if they do
with airfare, they could do it.
LISA GREEN: We have--
there's a particular brand
that we work with who's in
the sort of accessible luxury
space.
So their goods are about
$400, kind of in that range.
And what we've found
that's really interesting,
that their shipping is
actually quite expensive.
But for some reason, they
are still making sales,
even though their
product is actually
sold by other wholesalers.
What do you guys make of that?
We're trying to
figure out, is there
a reason why you think
consumers might still
prefer to buy brand-direct
versus from Shopbop
or Bloomingdale's
or Steven Allan?
How do you guys
sweeten the deal?
How do you get people to
buy something from you,
even if it's not
necessarily price?
Like, why buy it
from StevenAlan.com.
STEVEN ALAN: Well, I
mean, I don't know.
I guess with anything,
if I'm buying a product,
and it's from the source,
then I would think maybe it's
in better condition.
It's not coming off of
some shelf on a store,
where they're wrapping it up.
And if there is a problem,
that I can call that company.
And they'll certainly
stand behind their product.
Whereas if you're
selling another product,
you can only stand
behind it-- well,
you could stand behind it.
But it's not always the same
as if you're buying it direct.
I mean, I just-- actually
it doesn't relate.
I was just thinking of pillows.
Because I'm buying pillows.
But I can't think of
the analogy that I
wanted to think of, so, anyway.
[LAUGHTER]
BRETT HEYMAN: I just, for
me, I shop on Net-a-Porter
because it's very expedient.
Like it's fast.
It's same day.
That's something we offer
in New York on our site
and would love to roll it out
eventually at other places.
And you mentioned Spring.
We just had our Spring training.
And they're only offering one
mode and method of shipping.
I think everybody wants things
so fast that there's not
like-- you know,
normally you check out.
You have ground, expedited,
et cetera, et cetera.
And Spring is only
offering expedited.
So I just think--
STEVEN ALAN: It's also free.
BRETT HEYMAN: Yes.
LISA GREEN: It's free expedited.
LAUREN SHERMAN: Yeah,
I think the big reason
would be selection.
So assume that retailer may
have one or two things on-- you
can go to Edie Parker and
get probably everything
that you've done
that season, plus all
the personalization stuff.
Whereas, if you go
on Net-a-Porter,
there are probably
four SKUs or something.
I think that's a
big part of it is
that, I like to shop at
individual websites a lot.
Because it's usually
every single product
that they've done that season.
And when it's not,
I think, oh, you
didn't buy that for yourself?
And now I have to
go-- So you know,
so I think that
that's a part of it,
too, is just there's usually
a much bigger selection
on individual sites.
LISA GREEN: What about the
same day delivery thing?
I mean, you guys hopefully,
maybe have bought something
using Google Shopping Express.
But So we recently
launched it in New York.
It's been in the Bay
Area for quite awhile.
And we've got it in
West L.A. as well.
It's this idea that you can
not only get it same day,
but you can actually schedule.
Very similar to what you
do with Net-a-Porter.
It's subscription-based.
And right now, you get
six months for free.
So go home and try it out.
But what do you think about
that for fashion brands?
Because currently it's very
focused on everyday essentials.
It's Walgreens, Target,
Costco, Fairway.
Help me people.
What else am I missing?
L'Occitane.
Costco.
Toys-R-Us.
Yes, how can I forget?
I'm using it all the time.
So what do you think
about the likelihood
of fashion brands getting into
this space and the ability
to deliver goods same day?
Why would they say yes?
And why wouldn't they do it?
STEVEN ALAN: We've tried it.
We did it in holiday.
We did same day delivery.
We had messengers delivering it.
But I'm not sure.
I don't know what
would be involved
in doing it with Google.
Like, I don't know what the
costs would be for the company,
and how the whole
thing would work out.
So it would be hard to say.
LISA GREEN: So let's take
it from-- because I'm not
going to sell you the
product right now.
So let's take it from the sort
of consumer perspective, right?
Do you think that that's
something consumers
are really looking for now?
Or do you think that we've
got another year or two where
people are still happy
with two-day delivery
or whatever it is?
STEVEN ALAN: I think it's
always good to offer.
I mean, all things
being equal, I
think it'd be nice
thing to offer.
LAUREN SHERMAN: I would use it.
I think we are in a bubble of
a world where it's like, oh,
I can't go get that bag that
I really want for this wedding
this weekend.
Because I don't
have enough time.
So if someone could just
get it to me by Friday,
that'd be great.
And I definitely
pay extra for stuff.
So I think that people--
there is a need for it.
But it's just just a matter of
money and logistics in general.
When you're here, it's easy.
But if you're in
Idaho or whatever,
and you need a bag next
day, it's, you know,
it seem kind of impossible.
STEVEN ALAN:
Another thing too, I
was thinking about before
when you were asking about
the-- just when we're
talking about the fact
that your selection is so much
better in a single branded type
store.
It reminded me
of, there's a site
in Japan called Zozotown,
which is interesting
because they have all
these individual stores.
But it's kind of like a virtual
shopping mall, in a sense.
And people have
tried to do it here,
but I don't know
of anyone that's
really been effective
doing it here.
But it's pretty interesting.
LISA GREEN: It's essentially
what Google Shopping Express
is, just so you know.
It is.
It's all these different stores.
You're buying directly
from the store.
But it's being delivered
to you by Google.
So that's the--
STEVEN ALAN: So all the stores
are linked on Shopping Express?
LISA GREEN: Yes, so
it's basically a mall.
You should go.
Google.com/Express .
[LAUGHTER]
STEVEN ALAN: OK.
I'm going to check it out.
LISA GREEN: But just
so you guys know,
it's basically a mall where
you can buy from all this--
they're all local stores.
They're stores
you would go out--
LAUREN SHERMAN:
I definitely have
bought stuff via
Google Shopping.
Because I buy pretty
much everything online.
So I've definitely
done it before.
And I use it to
search for products.
LISA GREEN: Yeah.
Other questions from--
wait, I'm gonna go.
Betty Ann?
I'm just trying to
diversify the room here.
AUDIENCE: I'm Betty Ann.
I manage our Fashion and
Lifestyle Partnerships
on Google [INAUDIBLE].
And I've actually worked on some
capacity with most of you guys,
on the channel.
I just wanted to quickly ask
about [INAUDIBLE] and iBeacon
technology, and what your
thoughts are on that.
You mentioned a lot of
mobile and the features
in mobile, but what are you
guys thinking about [INAUDIBLE].
STEVEN ALAN: Cautious.
I mean, for me as a retailer
, just because I feel like
there's always that-- am I
invading your space by--?
But on the other
hand, I feel like it's
going to be so prevalent.
And it's going to be so
common in the future.
And so it's just a
question of doing it
in the appropriate way for me.
LEAH CHERNIKOFF: Yeah.
I mean, Elle is working
with iBeacon as well.
I think it's the same thing.
Like, I still
don't quite get it.
I'm like, OK.
So I just walk by something.
And if I have the thing,
it pops into my phone.
But yeah, I think it
would be about feeling,
walking the line of not
being too intrusive.
But if it's offering a
service, I think, everyone,
no one wants to-- You know,
it's those extra steps
that stop you from
making a purchase,
or getting something done.
So if iBeacon makes something
like that more seamless,
I think it's really helpful.
LISA GREEN: You have a question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Just wanted to follow up on
a thought that I was having.
When you mentioned
people price shopping
between different
sites, what you've
seen over the last-- probably
more than five years--
but an increase in
collaborations between stores
and designers
[INAUDIBLE] the sense.
[INAUDIBLE] Even bigger,
luxury retailers like Barneys,
they all have their
own exclusives.
Which in a way,
promotes their brand,
that they have all these things,
but it also prevents people
from comparison shopping.
So do you see that
becoming more prevalent?
More stores trying to
wake up with labels
and do direct
collaborations to keep
the customer at that store.
STEVEN ALAN: Definitely.
I mean, I think that as
much as you can do that.
Sometimes it's a little
tricky for some retailers.
Because let's say
you have one store.
And you want to
collaborate with a brand.
Usually the brand needs to
reach a certain minimum quantity
to produce.
So let's say it's 200 units.
And that could be
huge risk for you,
even though you have
exclusive products.
So, it's definitely a balance.
But I think that the more
you can do that, the better.
LISA GREEN: As a brand,
I mean that sounds
like a bit of a
challenge, to be creating
a unique product for every--
BRETT HEYMAN: It's
such a challenge.
And every market, every
important retailer,
now more and more demands
their own exclusives.
They want their own colors.
They want-- they
don't want you to sell
that bag to anybody else.
It's really, really difficult.
And I would just say in a-- I
love all of my retail partners
but-- I've noticed that,
especially with my brick
and mortar retailers,
they are very, very
specific about what they.
And they'll design something
based on what we design.
And I'm happy to oblige.
Because I'm a small brand.
But season after
season, I noticed
that those are the
bags that are still
on shelves at the
end of the season.
Like, I don't think
the customer cares
as much about exclusive to
x store as the store does.
STEVEN ALAN: Totally.
And I think that a
lot of times buyers
want to be designers too.
And it's sort of like,
what if we did this?
And we put the-- And
it's kind of like,
are you sure about that?
It's like, oh, yeah.
Definitely.
And we're going to buy it big.
A lot of times it's like
a big-- especially a store
chain or something like that.
And it's like you
kind of know it.
And then they get it.
And exactly what you said,
they're stuck with it.
And then you're like,
why did I do that?
I should have just
told them not do it.
And, but that happens sometimes.
And it doesn't really
merchandise back
with the collection.
It's sort of like
this one-off thing.
LEAH CHERNIKOFF: Yeah.
I think you do see
more and more of them.
But they only work when
they're really good.
And then they go.
And then you see it on
all your social channels.
Like, the message gets out.
Like, Lauren just wrote about
Everlane with Langley Fox.
But I think, and you
know, Barneys does a bunch
that I think are really good.
But--
LAUREN SHERMAN: Yeah, but
whether or not those ones
that they just did one
with the NBA player.
Russell--
LEAH CHERNIKOFF: Russell-
LAUREN SHERMAN:
Russell West-- yeah.
I just wrote a story about
NBA player style for Leah.
I obviously know a lot about it.
But I don't know
if those will sell.
They did one with
Jasmine Soule who's
a fashion consultant
who's super cool.
And everybody in fashion's
obsessed with her.
And they
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
I don't-- I mean, they probably
didn't make a lot of it.
But I think, the
one that Everlane
did with Langley Fox
who's an Illustrator.
And she's Ernest Hemingway's
great-granddaughter
or something.
Who cares?
The shirts were amazing.
And I bought three
of them immediately.
But it was cool.
She is cool.
And I was like, well, I
would like to look like her.
She's really cool.
She's-- but, it was more about
the product being really good.
And I think that's--
I love Steven did
with Katie Ermilio.
And it's completely different
price point and different kind
of customer.
But I happen to really like
both brands, so I got something.
So I think it has to
be the right thing.
AUDIENCE: It's either really
awesome, or clearance.
LAUREN SHERMAN: Yeah.
Totally.
LISA GREEN: Did you
still have a question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So I work with a
company I won't name
that's a global brand, household
name, where you can walk out
of here and see a million
dollar billboard with their name
on it.
LEAH CHERNIKOFF: This
is a fun guessing game.
AUDIENCE: And they still
don't believe in digital.
And so, for all of
you, I'm not an expert
in the fashion industry
like Katie is here.
[LAUGHTER]
I work with a bunch of
different [INAUDIBLE].
So I'm just wondering,
for each of you,
you've seen-- you've been
in the industry a long time.
[INAUDIBLE] more
watershed [INAUDIBLE]
digital [INAUDIBLE] that could
be more organic stuff, paid
media, online catalogs,
whatever it is.
For you, what was
your watershed moment,
where you saw and realized
how important online is
for the modern shopper?
STEVEN ALAN: I mean,
one thing in regards
to what you were saying-- I
mean, with online as opposed
to print, obviously,
you can track it.
So if you're a business and
you're going to advertise,
and you're going to take
out an ad in the magazine,
it's just sort of like, OK.
Well let's hope for the best.
It's like throwing darts.
But online, you're
actually seeing it.
You're actually seeing
the monetization
of what you're doing.
And I think in the
future, more companies
are going to look
at more the latent
demand of what's happening.
In other words, let's say
you're a retailer, a designer.
And you have
product on the site.
And you have buy 100 smalls,
100 mediums, 100 larges.
Right?
And you sell all the mediums.
So all you know
is, well I should
have bought more mediums.
Because I sold out.
But I think in the
future more and more
companies will start
looking at that data
not as, well, I
sold 100 mediums.
But 1,000 people clicked
on medium to buy it.
And I only had 100.
So not only did I
underbuy, but I really
should start to think about
just how I bought it in general.
I don't know if that--
LISA GREEN: it's hard to
believe that we're still
talking about people not
believing in online as just
a communication channel.
Is that why we're
silent, I think?
LAUREN SHERMAN:
I've had to write
a bunch of stories of brands
going online, and brands--
why aren't brands still online?
And I got online because
that's where I got a job.
And what are you going to do?
I wanted to work
at a Teen Vogue.
And I got a job at Forbes.com.
And it ended up
being great for me.
But I was not excited to work
in at a financial website.
And then I realized that,
oh, 30 million people just
read my story.
And I'm getting emails from guys
in India asking about-- like.
So I think that's
when you just realize
the power of the web and
the influence the web
has over print.
I mean, print still
has influence.
And it's still smart.
And I'm assuming that the brand
is at a very high price point.
OK, then I don't understand it.
[LAUGHTER]
Like, if you're
Chanel or Celine,
which are the only ones
that I can think of.
I mean, they don't
really need to.
Because A, maybe they
will need to someday.
But they sell a
ton of-- they sell
enough handbags to send
a 5,000 people to Dallas
for their $500 million
show or whatever.
But I think that
once you see the--
are they not selling
online at all?
Or they just don't want to spend
on digital advertising online?
AUDIENCE: They sell [INAUDIBLE].
LAUREN SHERMAN:
But they don't want
to spend on digital advertising.
Is that the--?
Well.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
LAUREN SHERMAN: Yeah.
I mean.
I think you really just
need to see the power of it.
Like what Steven said
about the 100 SKUs.
And then 1,000
people click on it.
You see how important it is.
And if they're still not
getting that, I mean,
I don't know what
their business is
going to look like
in five years.
But it's not going
to be-- I think
that they need to see its
power to appreciate it.
STEVEN ALAN: Also,
it's such a great tool.
I mean, for me, it's
all about the product.
It's about really building
this amazing product
and being able to
articulate that message.
So I feel like it's
enabled me as a designer
to sort of reach a much
broader appeal than I could
with just having stores and
let's say, if I was taking out
an ad in a magazine
or something.
You can really kind of dig
deeper and deeper on stuff.
LISA GREEN: We've got time
for one last question.
If anybody has it?
AUDIENCE: I'm curious to know.
So we've said a lot
in favor of online.
And I'm the typical
online shopper.
I buy everything online.
Do you see a counter-argument
against being fully online?
Do you think there's
still a place where
you need to have brick
and mortar partners?
And you need to have
your own storefront?
Or do you think you
could very easily
have your entire brand,
product line, on a website
and communicate solely online?
Or do you think it needs
to be kind of both?
STEVEN ALAN: I mean, I
think it could exist.
Certainly.
I mean, there's a
lot of companies.
I was talking to this
guy the other day.
And the business he picked
was the sexy business
of mattresses.
Which is like--
LISA GREEN: Pillows.
Mattresses.
STEVEN ALAN: Yeah.
It just happens.
I just happened
to meet this guy.
And he decided he was going to
start a mattress company called
Casper.
Casper-- beds.
Or Casper mattresses.
And basically it's all online.
And he's competing
with Sleep-Ease
and all the other-- I mean,
it's a huge, huge business.
And I just thought
it was interesting.
Because you can't see it.
So it's something that--
the mattress of all things.
You want to-- you lie down.
You do your test
and all that stuff.
So here's an example
where they're
selling a product that
traditionally has always
been a touch product.
And very successful with it.
So anyway.
BRETT HEYMAN: I know for me,
my product is so tactile,
that even though we're
doing well online,
I think there's still a
great benefit to people
feeling the acrylic and feeling
the confetti in it and all
the textures.
And I mean, this is
obviously a young room.
But there are people in my
mother's generation and people
who are very supportive
who are still not
comfortable buying
luxury online.
I mean like, Amazon,
Google-- one thing.
But luxury products-- they still
need to touch and feel and try.
LAUREN SHERMAN: I
think menswear, too.
I think guys really
want to try stuff on.
Or see it.
I was on Everlane the other day.
And my husband
was like, I really
want to try those polo shirts.
But I just wish there was
somewhere I could go look.
That's why I mean, Bonobos--
that's a whole other thing.
Whether or not I
believe in that product,
I'm not going to
talk about right now.
But I do you think the idea
of going into the store
and at least being
able to see it.
And he said that to
me just off-handedly.
And I think for
men, because they
tend to buy a bunch of the
same things-- is that right?
Yeah.
That they need to sometimes
to see it just once in person,
so they can just keep
buying it again and again.
STEVEN ALAN: Yeah.
LEAH CHERNIKOFF: They don't
like going into big stores.
STEVEN ALAN: I don't
think it's necessary
to have as many stores
as maybe in the past.
I think terms of building a
brand, you would think, OK.
Well you need to have all these
stores in all these cities.
And I think now-- I
mean, it's definitely
important to have stores
in all these key cities.
But, they're kind of
supplementing that experience.
So it really is a place to
sort of discover, touch.
And it's OK.
I think the more and more
it's seen as something that's
completely OK to
go in and not buy
something and just
kind of look at it.
And it's sort of like
this place to explore.
LISA GREEN: All right.
I'll leave my final
question-- I don't need that.
So we're frighteningly
already in August.
And so we're kind of
hitting that slope
into fall and then holiday.
If each of you could
just pick one big trend
that you're expecting to see
with the online, digital,
retail revolution, what do
you think it's going to be?
And we'll start with Brett
and go down the line.
BRETT HEYMAN: Just fast.
Getting everything fast.
That's all I keep hearing.
STEVEN ALAN: I think technology.
I mean, I'm seeing a lot
more technical fabrics
than I did before,
performance-based fabrics.
I think people are kind of more
and more curious about that.
LISA GREEN: Leah, you're up.
LEAH CHERNIKOFF: Yeah,
I think speed certainly.
And I mean, because--
I don't know.
I do think people wait
till the last minute.
I know I do.
So there's that.
And then if I were to name of a
product, I think the jumpsuit.
Yeah.
LAUREN SHERMAN: Yeah,
I think that people
are just more and
more interested.
And I think stores
and retailers are
going to try to
do more and more.
They're going to experiment
more with stuff in-store.
I know a couple of stories
that are opening here
in the fall that
are really trying
to make the store
experience immersive.
Maybe they're going
to go too far.
But people are definitely
experimenting a lot
with that type of
thing too, and bringing
that whole multi-channel thing
into Omni channel, or whatever.
I hate that word.
But you know what I mean.
LISA GREEN: Well
thank you guys again.
I hope everybody enjoyed it.
And we appreciate you
guys taking the time
to come down here.
[APPLAUSE]